lots to talk to Tobias Elwood who is the
chair of the defense select committee
conservative MP of course back venture
previous defense minister so much to
talk to you about but I just wonder if I
could pick up on on that
um so many unions going on strike at the
moment this is going to be a big problem
for your party well I'm pleased to see
the Prime Minister uh stepping forward
over the weekend calling in uh the
various parts of the public sector to
have those discussions I visited
Bournemouth Hospital uh last week
amazing to see the energy and
determination there they are to do their
job but this is a very very difficult
winter indeed because of covert and flu
and so forth we need to get the pay we
need to get the pensions sorted we need
to look at Recruitment and Retention I'd
like to see the bursary system come back
in for example that'll help recruit for
nurses to get them back in we've got
talks today education wise Jillian
Keegan is having those discussions so
I'm pleased to see a rejuvenated energy
coming in to solve this because
ultimately the longer these strikes go
on the harder they the more they damage
the economy and of course it's the
economy that we need to be able to pay
for them public sector as well okay
thanks for pivoting to that because I I
know that you were coming to talk to us
about Ukraine and also about
um uh Harry
um what was he thinking of when he was
talking about how many people he had
killed in Afghanistan
um I think like many sorry to see this
all play out I've got huge respect for
anybody that served in our Armed Forces
as serving particularly those who went
to Afghanistan
um but what we saw there I mean talking
about kill counts I think was
ill-advised deliberately put in the book
perhaps just as sensationalize But
ultimately we're very proud of our armed
forces the professionism that isn't just
about the combat Effectiveness it's how
we deal in the aftermath of battle you
know with prisoners of war with those
who are injured indeed those who have
been killed as well we go there because
for a higher cause to show that we are
an Exemplar of how we can fight
following the Geneva conventions and I
do worry that this is going to have
security implications one of the rare
occasions that I work with Prince Harry
was in the Invictus games in Sydney and
in Toronto and so forth incredible
effort this was his Design This was you
know his creation and I'm now concerned
that something which has been so
important to Veterans to help
Rehabilitation uh will now suffer
because there could be secure security
implications of him participating in
that well so you think that there's a
real worry about security with the
Invictus game I think it'd be good for
who who might to advise but from a
perspective from a military perspective
um this is something that's generated an
awful lot of discussion understandably
we simply don't talk about this and I
think clarification from Prince Harry as
to what he meant now you read the full
text of where he talks about this and
he's absolutely there for the right
reasons but that one sentence that talks
about the number I think it there needs
to be a clarification otherwise this
could easily Inspire jihadist extremist
groups who don't need much of an excuse
to find course to do the West
of course in Afghanistan again and they
there have been demonstrations their
reference to chess pieces now we need to
see that in context but even to use the
phrase of chess pieces when we're
talking about human beings some may see
as quite a challenge you know In the
Heat of battle any individual has to ask
themselves how they get through that day
indeed are they going to get through
that day but you keep those thoughts to
yourself or share them you know with
with your you know your fellow Soldiers
the idea that you then place it into a
book as I say I think that was
ill-advised and requires qualification
How concerned are we about the
continuing situation in Ukraine
obviously we are terribly concerned who
is winning that war really really good
question 2023 is a pivotal yeah we've
done so well in providing military
assistance but this is all about tactics
we now need to move on to strategy where
does this go where does this actually
lead to and it's so important that we
then look to say what is success what
does the mission involve what are we
trying to to to you know conclude this
year Russia's ability to endure hardship
is far greater than ours so I worry that
the West may lose interest so let's
confirm what our objectives are let's
actually make sure that we can provide
the weapon systems I would like to see a
weapons Factory in eastern Poland for
example created in order so there's a
long-term uh production line of
equipment rather than the ad hoc
contributions that are coming from the
West Odessa how often are we spoken
about getting the grain out of that uh
out of that Port still not happening you
know had the war not happened inflation
here in the UK would be just four
percent we go back to those strikes and
so forth what a different scenario that
would be in negotiating pay uh increases
and then of course there is long-term
security for Ukraine is Russia going to
then attack in a couple years time even
if we push them out this time they need
to be able to join an umbrella of
security there can't join NATO The Joint
expeditionary force is something that I
think they should be invited to join
these are all strategic objectives that
we can clarify this year 2023 will be a
critical year Okay so
sure you've had a look at the tool that
we launched yesterday uh what do you
think uh important all MPS can look at
their own electric and justify you know
where money comes from where it goes to
and so for how things are actually spent
so absolutely welcome you know any
scrutiny that provides that I think it's
important to perhaps distinguish between
what are created through the election
expenses because that's the way our
system runs in this case in the UK we
have to request uh so you know financial
support to run campaigns that needs to
be distinguished from uh appgs from the
visits that take place and so forth I
went on a delegation to Taiwan I've been
to Odessa as I just mentioned before I
went to Doha to meet the Taliban I'm the
only MP to have met the Taliban I
couldn't do these things without some
form of support and of course I'm I
earned extra funding through being a
reservist which is everybody's allowed
to do that and indeed as a vaccinator so
there are as indeed other MPS did as
well so there are ways that you know
those those numbers do add up separate
to what I think is is really the
headline grabbing stuff which is the
rather large sums that people are
earning
um separate to their work in in
Parliament themselves but again you
would then uh the argument is I think a
very powerful one as well we mustn't
lose connectivity with the people with
the businesses you know with the
communities that we represent But
ultimately every MP needs to look at
their own electorate in their own
consistency in the eye and say that they
justify you know what they've been
earning well you're a brave man because
um you're one of the few that have been
willing to come on to talk to us about
their figures and these are yours from
2019 uh declared 43 000 pounds in extra
income gifts and donations all
completely uh above board I hear the 10
listed sources of income the largest
being from Shabani yes Forum UAE
Ministry of Foreign Affairs 8650 the
smallest two thousand uh 300 if we give
me 300 puns from Renaissance strategic
advisors all completely above board as
we say how does it feel when you see it
in black and white well let's go back to
that very first figure because that's
where you started from I think 43 000.
it could be construed
um particularly if perhaps the audio
position you know down in Bournemouth to
say I've received 43 000 in gifts that
somehow I'm a beneficiary of that amount
of money and that's I think would be I
hope you'd agree would be misleading so
I think it will be helpful to make sure
that that isn't lost in what you're
trying to do which is ensure that
there's transparency here I've not
benefited from 43 000 pounds I've had to
go on trips to uh Ukraine you know to uh
to Taiwan to learn about what's
happening what threats are coming over
the horizon so I can sit here and speak
with some Authority on these matters
which we appreciate you doing I mean
just to make clear we don't combine
earnings and donations there are two
very separate things as you say and we
make that very clear uh as part of the
website that they are separate we've
already also separated them out into a
journalism earnings yesterday donations
um today so we make it you know very
clear that that figure for me 43 000 is
what many people may take away to say my
goodness Elwood is earning 43 000. and
we we both know that that's uh that's
incorrect so please that you're doing
this I think just understanding that I
think that's where you know MPS as a
whole would want absolute clarification
to be able to spell it out as to where
how that money adds up uh separate to
what might be you know being accumulated
as private earnings yeah well the um
as we know we only use uh publicly
publicly available information is what I
was trying to say simply a tool for
making the workings of parliament more
transparent and designed to give the
public a better understanding of how
politics is funded in this country but
you then look at how much somebody likes
Theresa May earns two point seven
million pounds since 2019
I deliberately said what I said earlier
that every individual MP and he's failed
to look at their own electorate and then
justify you know their earnings
themselves and the power of you know the
elections in this country people will
then make their own judgments on that or
listen to the justification as to uh
what you know how why that money was
earned in in what context I would also
add though that perhaps if I may humbly
uh you know ask to advance this is to
show how much is then given to charity I
don't know how much Theresa May gives to
charity of that amount of money or
indeed any MP the money I earned from
being a vaccinator I gave to a a caring
canines to my local charity which I'm
honored to be a patron of so I think
again the full context ultimately what I
wouldn't want I want scrutiny I think
every MP would want more scrutiny I'd
hate to see people being put off
becoming an MP even considering standing
for public office whether it be local
authorities or indeed in Parliament
because they they feel that somehow
um you know that when you're all that
add this up it's then further unfair
scrutiny so great you're doing this I
think wider context I think will be
really helpful yeah I mean MPS are not
obliged to say how much money they give
to charity some MPS do some don't it's
up to them I mean if Theresa May is
watching this morning good morning to
you Mom if you'd like to tell us how
much you give to charity I'd be thrilled
to come and come and talk to me tomorrow
make room for you anytime between seven
and ten do you think that MP should have
second jobs uh yes I do
um because there is a and I see this a
lot it's very easy to be caught up in
that Westminster bubble to be segregated
you know from The Wider world and
understanding what's going on you can
tell and and you've had people on the
sofa when they know what they're talking
about and when they don't what they're
don't know what they're talking about
and you can see that in the chamber as
well so those people that do have a
connection with a business an
understanding of what's going on so so
important to have that connectivity but
it needs to be done responsibly okay
it's always great to see you happy new
year thanks thank you for joining us
thank